i can't wait to hear it jake
are you gonna sing at the same time are
we rolling components inside
let me just try it real slow and then
you guys and i'm just gonna try it real
slow i'm gonna try not to mess it up
okay
is this the podcast this is when people
are like jake no one came here to hear
your guitar
there's there's been more comments
aggressive comments lately commenting to
all those people saying i didn't come
here to hear your guitar jake here's
what i have to say to you
stop listening to our podcast
that's right get out of here take that
hate somewhere else wow yeah guys press
pause on hate real quick thank you
that's a real press pause didn't it hit
resume later
sorry you're right that's a terrible
phrase
hit stop
all right inject that hate use ripple
delete
use ripple delete
shift delete that hate just erase
history
[Music]
that's how it goes
and i don't know the whole thing but um
well it just sounds better the more you
get the thing there's there's this
alternating like four five six like
thumb picking pattern that basically
gives it like this this like humming
bass line and it sounds like it's two
guitars at once um it's pretty amazing
uh to hear it played correctly which is
not from me but i'm hoping to get there
one day anyway you will
keep practicing man yeah i know exactly
what you mean
i've been able to do it for a few years
now
yeah yeah ren's
everybody doesn't know this but ren is
actually a famous musician
yeah
wait okay nevermind
i'm just gonna end it there there's no
reason to pursue this bit there's a
famous folk song called grandma jean
that has the same kind of thing with
like this alternating bass line if you
look it up on youtube it's like
it kind of sounds like a video thing
it's a common it's a common pattern that
gets used it's just
it's like it's like learning a new
effect or learning a new skill like once
once you learn the bass then you can
apply it to all these other songs and i
i never
i've never been
driven enough
until i heard this particular song to
want to learn this this pattern and so
now i'm like i have to learn this
pattern
that's the best when you when you hear a
song and you're like i'm gonna learn
this and then you pick up a new
technique from it yeah that's that's
what you need to learn an instrument is
like a song that you want to learn the
real
the real like
epicness of it though
comes from the stories and like the
musicians
and the stories of the guys who
were at the cutting edge of that
and were like you know learning it from
each other
new techniques that people hadn't ever
heard before
that novelty
yes novelty but but in a way
thing
i mean i guess it is it is true novelty
you're right wren
yeah novelty is at the heart of any
creative
pursuit of mine you know what's
hilarious right now is that i have you
on discord and uh i can see i can see
nico and nick and then i can see your
legs and i have all the other people in
chat on right but it just so happens
that your legs get cut off
and then you're in chat
exactly at the point where your head
would be
[Laughter]
that's really funny
hey this podcast start it must have
started i think
hey how's it going everyone thanks for
tuning in to our podcast we have a lot
of things to talk about today
yeah do we probably the biggest one that
if you're seeing the title to this video
and you're like get to the point already
what's up with this song
we had a very special guest on visual
effects artists react yesterday we did
his name
yeah
no it was uh it was seth rogen
whoa surprise seth i didn't read the
title of the podcast
seth wrote i mean if you follow any of
our social media you'll know that at
this point we we were like
we should probably like play it cool you
know try to keep it under wraps and then
like i keep checking through the night
and there's like more and more photos
coming up on my own yeah we talked about
it yesterday it was like is this
something that we should keep a secret
until the episode drops is this
something that we should kind of like
play
uh even particularly extra cool like
yeah oh yeah and you just happen to have
an episode of seth rogen go out today no
big deal check it out if you're
interested
and then it's like when it came down to
it like uh nico made a point that i i
agree with and it's like the whole idea
of secrecy i think
isn't really as powerful as
you might hope or i forget how you
phrased it it was a little bit a lot
more eloquent than how i just said it
but damn i'm just naturally eloquent huh
i mean
yeah uh yeah and so at the end of the
day it was kind of like well it's like
why not why not like what are we gaining
from keeping it a secret what are you
doing niko well in this case in this
case you're not gaining a whole lot what
you want to keep what you usually want
to keep off of social media is like
the stuff that you're actually capturing
with camera
that's going to appear in the final
piece to which all the money from the
budget is going right and you don't want
to have somebody be releasing something
that's going to be in that
yeah exactly but this is just like
guys sitting on a couch and you know
reacting to
to footage and and
not from the same angle of the camera
not cut like that yeah so it's a little
bit different
yeah and
ultimately this was just incredibly cool
yeah it's kind of hard to not share the
the news it's pretty sweet it was really
cool yeah so should we kind of like do a
bit of story yeah like story time story
time so the story actually starts with
wren
yeah okay so uh last year right at the
beginning of lockdown like mid march mid
to late march of 2020 i get a random dm
on
twitter from seth rogen being like hey
man
big fan love the show and i was like the
what
it was like it was like the first time
an actual legit like mega star like
acknowledged my existence well hold on
and tom cruise came down to our studio
oh my god my bad but so hold on a second
so about the time will smith hit us up
oh that's true but i wasn't there for
that or the time that soup dog hit us up
i wasn't there for that either
this is like this is a big personal one
for me i was like
did you have to double check to see if
it was the real i did i straight up had
to check i mean well i saw the blue
check mark right away so i was like okay
that's not just it
i mean
this is twitter this doesn't have blue
checkmarks to anybody they don't just
sound like checkmarks to anybody but no
it was very it was like one of those
weird surreal moments i was like i
checked and it's like even though i saw
at every point that this was real i was
still in my head just like there's no
way this is real and
obviously i got over that pretty quickly
and uh we chatted for a little bit and i
was like hey i mean
maybe once uh this pandemic thing is all
over we can uh collab on something he's
like yeah that'd be great and that was
march 2020.
that was back when we all
naively thought this was just gonna be
like a a couple months of annoyance and
then it'd be over
uh yeah here we are a year and a half
later right um
anyway
and that was pretty much it and i pretty
much spent the the rest of that of last
year and this year kind of just thinking
of ideas i've got several ideas for like
corridor shorts that we could do with
seth
random different ideas that we can do
together but it's still like just one of
those things that's like do i hit him up
like he's busy he's making like movies
and stuff like
i don't know that's not weird like like
am i valuable enough to the world of
filmmaking and art and like do enough
people watch my stuff to justify me
reaching out to someone like
seth rogen yeah do something with us and
it's like you know if i had the right
project
i would have no problem you know
reaching out to someone like him like i
i have a contact let's do it i've done
it for other random things like that in
the past that have worked out i don't
know it's just like i got in my head a
little bit too too frequently and just
never ended up doing it and that goes to
the next part of the story so the next
part of the story is uh this is where i
take over for a minute here so it's
about a month and a half ago
and
i'd never check my instagram dms like
the the general ones from people i don't
follow like you know if a friend sends
me a dm it'll pop up like a text message
but
for people i don't follow or just i i
never look at them
um so i don't really use instagram as
like a platform for talking to anybody
it's mostly just for posting pictures
once in a while and that's it do you are
you talking about like the the
accepted messages or even just like the
because you know anybody can send you a
message and
i i don't get thousands of them but i
get a hand you know a handful everyone's
not the same way like i have like the
primary messages list that i pretty much
just put everything into in the general
list and then the uh the requests the
request
and within the request you can sort by
new um sort by how many followers
they're sort by follower size and that's
that's a fun one because you can
instantly be like all right who famous
has sent me a message
yeah and he's like oh wow okay okay
instagram famous there's a little shirt
yeah there actually should be a few
asterisks on that is someone with like a
hundred thousand followers
is that really a check mark in the shape
of an asterisk
a little blue asterisk sorry
but still though it's like you know it's
an easy way to just like
all right is this message worth my time
maybe something will come up i'll look
at it at least i get only like one
person a day who who i don't know sends
me a message on instagram but like i
said it's
i just don't check it very often and
maybe check it once every two or three
weeks so i just happened to check it and
literally an hour before i check it is a
message
sent to me from a man named seth the
blue checkmark next to his name
and says hey i really like your show
wait a minute
is this the seth and then uh sure enough
it is and i cannot believe that i
managed to look at my messages on the
same day that he sent me one because how
bad would it have looked if two weeks
later i got back to him like oh hey cool
you know
oh my gosh
uh so i haven't wishing he had because
then he would have just hit me up again
um
so
you know i was like no this is crazy i
need to respond and so i'm gonna put i'm
gonna out mike here i'm sorry mike but
i'm sure the lonely island guys don't
listen to this podcast uh
so what they they definitely do they're
listening right now just
baited breath
now you've called them out yeah yeah
well my yeah now they called them out
but so mike uh works with them here and
there you know he did the uh the bash
brothers thing on netflix with them and
uh
you know
just like me like they're they're
filmmakers that he looks up to immensely
um you know they really paved the way
for a lot of like the stuff that got us
into filmmaking you know they're big on
channel 101 before youtube wasn't even a
thing
um
so you know when these people hit you up
that you really look up to
you and you try to type a text message
back to them it's like you get like five
words into it like this is the dumbest
sounding thing like it's either like
everything's all properly capitalized
and punctuated it's like this is way too
formal it sounds like you're spending
too much time on it and then you like
try to write it casually like this is
way too cause now i sound like an idiot
greetings seth again
greetings fellow citizen
hello mister rogen that's like god dang
it uh anyways so what's up what mike
does is that i did you know it's not
dude uh what mike does is he opens
notepad and he types
he types his responses in notepad first
so that they each the other person can't
do that
yeah yeah so you know imagine you said
you know you don't want to sit there
like oh they're going to type reply and
then like 10 minutes later it's like
they still haven't hit send
i find it so funny the hidden social
dynamics of communication on the
internet it is so funny like these laws
we constrain ourselves to but it's like
real it's like
yeah you know like you don't talk to
someone and just be like one second
come into the corner
and like stand in the corner just like
turn away
like stupid
text messaging was like irl
we should make a little short about that
real life conversation
yeah
but it's like yeah you know it's those
little three dots that's that's an
actual legit thing that you gotta it's
it's part of the conversational dynamic
it's like you can't just ignore it it's
like
and especially like sometimes it's like
if there's someone i haven't talked to
in a long time and i'll accidentally see
one of their instagram stories
they're gonna know that i've seen that
story now because it shows you and i've
got this image that is nice bright red
i'm like oh god dang it
yeah i mean that's that's a stupid
example but i guess what i'm saying is i
use notepad anytime i need to uh write
something that i need to put a lot of
thought into because a text box
uh for a comment or something is just
not a good spot because you can only see
like the previous 40 characters or so
and if you got like a big response
it's a thing so i get it dude the worst
is when you see the dots
and they're there for like a minute then
they disappeared
you don't get a message for like hours
oh man
you're like okay this is really a second
hand message i just received
maybe they were maybe they were going
okay wait is this too formal wait is
this too casual
you know what i'm just i'm just going to
respond to the later nervous ones
that's the whole like what do you call
it the double the the double aspect
where you i can't even think of the
phrase right now i have a bad headache
taunt well no like the
standard the double standard of that is
like oh i gotta make sure you get so in
your head about things but then if you
were receiving that you saw the dot dot
dot it's like no they can't possibly be
trying to formulate a better sense this
is personal yeah this is this is a
personal slide this is the only possible
option but if i'm doing it no
i haven't realized i have an interesting
question about this and i've and i'm
wondering if this only happens to me
or if this happens to other people
there's a few people in my life
thankfully none of them at corridor but
there's a few people that i've met along
the way
where i've literally been i've realized
that my problem isn't that i don't get
along with that person
my problem is that
that person and me are almost the same
person oh yeah and and it's like we
i can't communicate with that person
because it's like it's like it's like
about bouncing into a wall cancels every
time you talk to him yeah
um
and this has happened with like three
people in my life
and has this ever happened to you guys
oh 100
okay 100
do you still talk to those people are
they like in your life or were they i
mean yeah my mom's still in my life
i did notice a really stark similarity
you know honestly i feel like i have a
healthy like professional relation
respectful relationship with those
people but it's hard to definitely like
be friends with them per se yeah you
know it's like puzzle pieces yeah you
want the i don't know what there's
probably actually like puzzle terms for
like the knob and the socket you know
socket
but yeah you want them to fit together
right um so anyways uh after
sit in notepad for like 20 minutes um i
eventually composed my response and sent
it over which is just basically you know
amounts to like hey i really appreciate
you taking the time to say that um means
a lot
and yeah super flattered and
thank you you know more or less what
boiled down to
and then i'm like cool
and then there's a part of me that goes
if you don't ask a question you will not
get a response
i'm like oh i should ask him to be on
the show and then it's like then it's
just back down the rabbit hole of like
is it too
soon do i have the social power to ask
this question
three messages first
i mean like
you know what if you don't like imposing
somebody where it's like i was just
trying to tell you that yeah i liked
your show i didn't want to like make it
a work thing
this is like we are two in the heads the
show yeah
so anyways long story short i tried to
just like shrug all that off and just be
normal
which i i can get most of the way there
oh you probably did yeah you probably
were well he he showed up so i clearly
did something right yeah yeah
he played it he played it cool but
anyway so i eventually asked him like
hey you know would you have any interest
in coming on um
you know seeing that you've written
directed produced acted at all these
things and
and then he responds a little while
later you know whatever the day goes on
he eventually responds with yeah man if
you wouldn't have asked me i was going
to kind of push myself to come on this
show like that made me feel a lot better
yeah um it's like okay phew yeah all
right this is
less of uh
an inconvenience to you than i initially
worried
yeah
so that was really cool and it just like
it was really neat to know that
he was excited about it and wanted to be
on the show and one of the things that
he mentioned when he was uh filming with
us
was he takes a lot of inspiration from
youtube and just kind of that world of
reality you know for example he pointed
out like
you know watching america's funniest
home videos montage a 20 minute long
montage is going to make you laugh more
than most comedy movies do
and it's like that's what he has to
compete with is like that's because all
the stuff is at your fingertips now on
youtube and when he's writing comedy
like that's what he's competing with
um and so he will spend a lot of time
watching that stuff and trying to figure
out like why does it work and how can he
pull some of these elements into his
films
um so you know it's not just vfx artists
react but
you know a whole bunch of stuff on
youtube he also brought up like every
frame of painting yeah and i can't
remember
who he was talking to i think it was a
cinematographer he was the
cinematographer for
edgar wright for some of his movies uh
it mentioned that like even that guy
like watching every frame of painting
he's like oh i didn't know i did that
that's really cool
i often feel like those like youtube
analysis breakdowns go way too deep into
things and like find weird patterns that
no one on set thought of and it's like
sometimes that is intentional but
sometimes it's not you know when like
you're in in school or whatever and you
got a book assignment you got to read it
and then uh the
teacher goes over all like the analysis
of it is like oh the theme of this
character choosing to do this
uh while also having the imagery of this
in the background is like that means
this one thing and
as a student you're just like
no
but then as you get older and you start
incorporating that some of that stuff
into your own work you're like well i
mean i guess maybe
maybe and then you get to these
situations where like let's say we put
out something and someone else does a
whole breakdown let's say we are edgar
wright and someone did a breakdown of
our movies and you know i'm wright
sitting there going
yep that's that's totally totally what i
was intending yeah
i think
totally
yep yep i'm great
sometimes talented people just do stuff
because it feels right though like i
don't think there's always intention and
there's patterns that can be recognized
sometimes yeah it's like there's
intention but it's not necessarily
conscious
that is like kind of the basis of a lot
of art there are ancient um uh like
symbols and ways of of introducing
different types of characters and
ways of telling stories though that that
like go
can be related all the way back to like
our our origins as a species and things
like that and i think some of that like
even though it's not direct it just kind
of filters through
in the process of of just creating i
think it comes back to patterns honestly
yeah there's like basic human struggles
and themes
and yeah they were doing the same thing
thousands of years ago for sure isn't
that like isn't there a thing where
there's actually only like something
like a couple dozen or a few dozen
different
stories
yeah
can basically be brought down to one of
these core branches of story type yep
i i don't remember the specific number
what those stories are i think it's
interesting i think it's only five if
i'm not mistaken i studied this for a
little bit but forgot most of it like
there's the heroes journey there's like
others
yeah
but yeah so you know seth rogen came
into the show you know we talked on
instagram a little bit and he
we set a date and uh managed to make
time in his schedule and he came on out
one of one of my favorite things was at
the end of the shoot so like anytime we
have somebody else in the shoot we
usually promote something it's like it's
like a talk show you know it's like you
know imagine going on like jimmy kimmel
and like usually they're doing it as
part like actors or whomever is doing
this part of like a press tour for
something yeah so what's your plug kid
yeah exactly we get to the end like is
there anything you want to promote he's
like no
it's like are you sure we can push
people somewhere he's like
uh
well let's promote total recall
series we just promote the 1990 film
total recall
so we're gonna have to come up with like
graphics for like you can stream
i don't know if that speaks to him just
being on a whole other level where it's
like he's so
prolific that he doesn't need to plug
stuff i mean he said that he's like oh
my stuff's out there yeah yeah which is
a pretty polite way of saying like
everyone knows who i am yeah i'm fine
this won't make a debt um but
i think it more speaks to
the way i saw it honestly was like he
was just excited to be there and like
get to nerd out with you guys
that was incredibly cool and that showed
i think and it'll show in the episode i
think there's no vibe of like
forced yeah yeah and it's like i've
gotten questions of like what was it
like like how did you feel like were you
excited and it's like well yeah it was
very exciting and i was less nervous
than i
uh thought i might be in like the hour
or two leading up to it
um i'll get into what was actually on my
mind in the hour or two leading up to
that in a bit but uh yeah and and yeah
it's like he came in and was like
that is seth rogen hi nice to meet you
and he's like hi and uh and whatnot is
like
incredible women so normally it was just
a very normal experience it's like it's
another person this literally could have
been anyone walking in the door that
i've never met before
but the it yeah when a human being talks
to another human being ran there's a
very special thing that happens called
communication
yeah but like i don't know i've i have
met a lot of fans who are who know who i
am and i've seen i'm sure you're in the
same boat where it's like
they know a lot about us and we know
nothing about them and they they make a
lot of assumptions about who we are
based on what they've seen based on what
we've put out there and so sometimes
that can kind of either create a
disconnect or they get really
overwhelmed when they meet us and uh
it's like now i have to deal with you
being overwhelmed about meeting me and
it's like i've i can do that that's fine
that's not a big deal i've done it
enough
but
at the same time they're just like i'm
just not used to they they say it they
literally verbalize to to me that
they're not used to talking with someone
that they've seen a lot
and that was literally the exact same
position that we were all in the moment
seth showed up true well we played it
cool
yeah you have to i mean at the other day
everybody's still just a person you know
yeah it's uh
like
i had a lot of in not i guess some
interactions but a lot of exposure to
famous people when i interned at mtv for
a summer when i was like 20 oh my gosh i
forget about that yeah i still don't
even know who you he interacted with a
lot of people actually um
yeah
daisy clan jim gym class heroes
steven dobrik uh
50 cent on the escalator
like
uh but i legitimately interacted with
you know famous people and
most the vast majority of people aren't
famous because they are
you know
one in a billion hyper
charismatic effectively aliens you know
most people are famous because what they
do as their profession puts them out
there in front of people
um
you know like like a news anchor for
example like a famous news anchor
they're honestly famous because like god
that person is just so cool you mean
like always you mean like ellie's steve
koosh
like ellie's steve kuge uh you know like
most people are famous because like you
know it's like i'm a musician and music
is something that just is
uh consumed by a lot of people so you're
going to have people know what you do
and they're going to know your name
um
and so you know that's something i have
to like remind myself like when
interacting with somebody like seth or
even just like another big youtuber is
just like yeah you know put all that
away it's just another person doing
their thing and like yeah you have a lot
of exposure to them and the videos that
you've seen of them but like
it's just another professional out there
doing their work and doing what they're
passionate with um and just like any
other human being out there so i was
very impressed with how professional
seth was like yeah it was getting close
to two he was supposed to show up at 2
p.m that was like the meeting time right
and it was kind of getting close to that
and he hadn't shown up yet it was still
early and like chris and i were like i
mean like
he could be half an hour late maybe
that's just his thing like i guess it
wouldn't be out of character as far as
what the public knows but like he showed
up exactly at two he was
shockingly on time
oh then he may have been early yeah yeah
he's like christian's like i'm gonna go
check to see and like literally came
back with seth rogen i was like oh god
he's here
too
but um yeah i mean
it was comforting to know that like
you know people are on the show i guess
honestly everybody we've had in the show
has watched the show which is
interesting like we haven't had a
situation where somebody's on the show
and they've just never seen it before
but even so it was comforting it was
really comforting and
helped make it easier to know that he's
watched a lot of these episodes so he's
coming in having spent
15 minutes every saturday with us you
know and just like we're coming into
this having spent you know chunks of two
hours with him uh watching you know the
films and so
you have like a double para social
relationship thing yeah it's really odd
both have like
perceived projections of the other
person as from watching videos
yeah and like uh
you know
when you have a video get get a million
views or
many videos get many views uh in our
case it
it's it's very hard to kind of like wrap
your head around like who out there is
actually seeing these videos and this is
a pretty good example of
you know who knows how many other like
big directors or actors or whoever
famous people that we know are seeing
our stuff on a regular basis that we
just have no idea
probably like neil blom camp or
something's probably seen them
probably
probably probably i hope i hope he joins
us i hope we can get that worked out
yeah i mean
have we talked about that yet i don't i
don't know if we've never talked about
that i was actually lying in a schedule
casually in case we didn't want to talk
about it
yeah no he had him he i mean he's a fan
of the show too uh
sam and him talked a bunch one or two
years ago around when the boss town
series were dropping and
uh yeah he had he was doing a thing he
was going to be in town for a press tour
and was going to be on the show but due
to uh the delta variant and various
other things it just fell through yeah
um
it will still happen yeah i mean i think
it will i think it will even if it means
like we actually go up to vancouver to
film it should we go to canada
yeah i mean i guess what i'm getting at
is
seth's point was that
a lot more people of his caliber watch
youtube than anyone on youtube really is
um
aware of it yeah exactly yeah you mean
just like normal people yeah
like what do you mean you mean people
who everybody watches youtube it's like
everybody watching
no dude which is also really
intimidating like oh it's like all these
shots that we've dunked on i'm so sorry
that we already knew because the artist
who would work on those shots that we
would dunk on would hit us up
yeah think there's an appreciation for
some of that stuff because
to the traditional industry youtube's
still a little bit
edgy you know there's not a bunch of
producers involved
at every step of the way to try to
and there's also a lot mirror everything
to make it perceived in a certain way
there's always a lot of control over
what a lot of those people can say yeah
uh even like even artists or whatever
you know they're like they're not
allowed to talk about something until an
embargo drops and even then obviously
they're not going to you know just dunk
on anyone because that's their industry
and so we are in a weird position where
we can do that without repercussions but
it's not like i want to personally i
don't understand it's honesty
it's yeah it's 100 exactly 100 what it
is like because yeah if you're in the
industry
you you don't say you can never say like
oh that was a shitty movie i made right
and honestly like like guys we're all
just making movies like who the [ __ ]
cares you can say you made a shitty
movie like thousands of shitty movies
come out every year but like if you're
in the industry like how dare you yeah
how dare you say like disrespected yeah
it's just it's a scary thing to do
sometimes because you can piss off the
wrong person and at least you know it
doesn't actually lead to big things but
it just leads to hassle and so
everybody's very careful and perhaps it
creates a bit of an environment of like
you know being nice to each other which
is good but it also creates an
environment where
you sometimes you just you can't relax
and not take yourself seriously and just
be like that was a bad vfx shot you know
or whatever
um and yeah like you're saying wren we
are in a position where we can do that
but truth be told like when you watch a
bad vfx shot you know it's a bad vfx
shot like there's no need to sugarcoat
it and just say it's a bad vfx shot and
if it bugs you out like cool well it's
funny because some of them some of the
most prolific people in the traditional
industry
they they've they've gone through that
yeah and they've been honest about stuff
and maybe it's bit him in the ass a few
times but overall
it's like it's a
it's a it's a hoop of fire though
and yeah and if you really want to get
to the other side you got to jump
through it at some point and you you
might not make it you might get caught i
might start on fire you know
but there's a few on the other side and
you're like yo i see i see you over
there
yeah and you know those people have done
it because because they've been able to
be honest about stuff but you know it
yeah it's it's interesting because it
creates both things like you said like
there's an environment where you
maybe you're being
facetious to people
and there's also an environment where
it's like well let's just try to respect
the craft be for the craft itself
because it's hard enough to do to begin
with right and both of those things
are happening at the same time
so seth did tell us about the movie he's
currently working on and i'm not going
to give any details except what's
already listed on imdb publicly he is
currently starring in a movie by steven
spielberg called the fableman's and uh
so he was saying last set or the episode
with your dad uh uh alex laurent who
worked on you know minority report uh
saving private ryan spielberg movies
seth told us like yeah i was just
sitting there in my trailer watching the
episode and then when the episode
finished i was like that was cool put in
my pocket now i'm gonna go get direction
from spielberg
walked out his door he's like yo what's
up steven and the same cinematographer
there was a picture of them too lining
up a shot in the video and he's like
yeah and then i looked and they were
right over there
so yeah that was really trippy because
it's like okay weird small world things
going on yeah and they wrote an article
about your dad did you see that screen
rant
featuring uh your dad's defense of
the the worst vfx shot in history
i talked to him the other night about
that actually he's like man i wish i had
like i wish i'd had more energy because
i was like at the end of our like mummy
session before we broke for lunch
and yeah he was like damn if i knew they
were gonna like
like put me out in an article i would
have like gone way more in depth on the
scorpion king
it was an overly ambitious thing for the
time
and we did our best and one of the
things we tried to do was just hide it
as much as we could because we knew it
wasn't working
everyone's reaction was not a reaction
we were not having you know it's like we
see the same thing that you guys saw we
just tried
and and at the end of the day it's a
freaking man it's the wrong stitch to a
scorpion like yeah so what
if it's a goofy shot
he was like i wish i would have talked
more about how much of a time constraint
they were under those as well because
like he kind of touched upon the the
mocap technology because they were
contractually obligated to use the
rock's face
and like get it and like
like there was all this like
super constrained timing that meant that
they had to get it done like in a crazy
low amount of time so that's usually the
reason for bad visual effects is that
for one reason or another there's just
not enough time
yeah and all the other shots actually
look really good yeah i mean
people forget that's a whole sequence
like a 20 minute part of the movie where
like they're like dancing around
fighting like three shots are great
and it wasn't enough to discourage the
rock from doing
a standalone scorpion king movie
it's just because it's the reason why
it's so iconic is because it's the first
shot of of that character yeah yeah
yeah that's why
yeah it's good
so well
what can you do
but yeah so like uh you know seth's on
the couch with us that was like when it
when we we we're trying to like you know
warm up a little bit you know hang out
yeah
kind of talk around a little bit because
i didn't want to start right away you
don't want to like you never do like
that's you always warm up yeah it's like
you want to have like a little bit of
time to get comfortable and then we can
actually start having
uh you know the show go and
sitting down on the couch right here
seth rogen is just like this is where it
got surreal like in my head i'm like
this is actually happening cool um but
also it's like we're working we're
professionals and it wasn't like i
didn't get in my head around it you know
it was like i'm this could have been
clint for all i cared in the moment uh
we're just talking you know vfx and as
soon as we got going it was like pretty
much immediately i realized
this is going to be amazing
because yeah he just
has a very very smart guy very smart
that's the thing everyone always
pictures seth rogen as like the stoner
dude because he you know he does so many
drugs and he's kind of cultivated that
sort of like uh image but at the same
time
this dude is one of the most prolific
producers for being also a writer
director
actor
yeah
and and i think it'll be very apparent
once people start listening to him
talking with us breaking down scenes
giving us the context as to the
decision-making process for certain
visual effects in his movies and he just
had a lot to say
a lot of the time with guests we kind of
have to like
not try hard but you have to kind of
encourage them to
you know give a little bit more context
or explain a little bit more or drop a
little factoid that's interesting you
know we had the opposite problem with
seth rogen
it's not a bad thing but i found myself
being like i am struggling to find
i don't think he was like talking like
too much or like over talking but like
exactly he was
touching upon like everything you guys
would normally steer the conversation to
yeah he even like pulled out some
tidbits that you
we were looking at escape from los
angeles i had the whole like little in
my back pocket the little factoid of
like oh and they did wireframes back
then they couldn't afford computer
animation so they just painted
wireframes on models and filmed it and
as you pulled the shot i was like
so in this shot they actually had uh
they couldn't afford wireframes actually
like sam you stole my you stole my fun
facts
escape from los angeles it was just like
we'd watch like one or two of his movies
so i wanted to have you know let's bring
up this one a random one we didn't warn
him ahead of time he had no idea this
was gonna happen and we're gonna start
talking about and he literally dropped
that right before niko could
yeah
it was cool you know it's also it's one
of those episodes where you could
effectively upload the whole thing uncut
and every moment of it would be
fascinating well good thing we have
a website with extended cuts of vfx
artistry that's true and we did our
first extended cut last week with uh
scott atkins uh because you know on
youtube the episodes need to be edited a
certain way and play out a certain way
and there's there's algorithms to worry
about there's a lot of copyright issues
we have to dance around like there's a
bar of quality we have to maintain yeah
and there's also a breadth of audience
we have to keep in mind you know those
those videos get a million views and you
have everybody from like huge film nerds
watching them slash
working professionals like in the
industry all the way to like just the
most casual people who just you know
think it's cool
and that's great you know i'm glad we
can make a show that appeals to all of
those people but like to then focus in
and be like okay let's get a little more
hardcore and let's delve into some of
these pieces a little bit more deeply
that would cut off half of that audience
and you know make it inaccessible to
them but we at least know that with the
website you know that's for those people
on the website or the subscribers
subscribers on the website are people
are passionate about these videos and we
can now
give an avenue for people who want like
who are really big fans of like vfx rs
react and stuff and react you know this
is an avenue for them to actually get
into these episodes and get like 25
minute long episodes they're still
really good but they just they're just a
touch slower and there's a few less
illustrations because there's more
talking
uh and it just it goes deeper into this
stuff and they're still super
fascinating like the episode of scott
atkins that's on the website is so good
and the stories he tells are so great
so yeah yeah but in the world of youtube
you really have to uh pay attention to
pacing and it's like the moment things
slow down it's like on youtube you start
losing people and it doesn't matter how
many people say like oh it's fine i'll
watch it just make it longer no big deal
it's like
you're not making sure you do videos you
don't know how to do it
i will say though i think
with seth's episode we have a bit more
wiggle room with the attention span
factor on youtube and i think one
hundred percent
can be longer cuts for this one yeah it
is a special occasion and i think
um i it would be an interesting
experiment to do like a 20 minute
episode for youtube
and then and we maybe just put it up
uncut on the website this is i will say
there wasn't a lot of like false like
statements or like stumbling sorry i
just wanted to no no it's like this is
the first time i can ever remember
filming an episode after two plus years
where after the first hour i i
legitimately had the thought wow
the previous hour that we just shot we
can literally upload uncut and it would
be great yeah like
blew my mind yeah once again jackie chan
i mean working with like people that are
of that caliber it's just going to be
easy especially when they're comedians
because comedians are so good at
improvising and keeping something going
and like playing playing with
conversations and playing with ideas i
mean that's literally what they're
trained to do
um and so if you yeah it's like
not like you look at what joe rogan does
and it's and it seems easy
for him to just have these conversations
with all these people
from all walks of life or for seth rogen
to sit down with us and just go on and
on about different types of
films
but it's truly a skill to just be able
to do that to have that knowledge and to
understand like okay this is what
somebody else is going to find
interesting yeah so i'm going to talk to
that not just like kind of randomly
about something
100 100 and that's the distinction i
think most people don't realize
yeah
yeah being able to talk to what the
person on the other the audience member
finds interesting
versus
just talking yeah yeah it's really
tricky and i mean that's that is our job
you know me and ren when we are with the
guests or from stuntmen react like you
know me and freddie or ghee or whomever
like that is our job is to constantly
guide that back to what is interesting
and we didn't have to do any of that
yesterday yeah yeah although i will say
like right off the we watched total
recall first that was the first thing we
got into and it was like it's like a
warm-up it was yeah it was our warm-up
and it was interesting and like we
looked at like and i was doing way too
much talking
i'll get to that it wasn't that it was
too much talking it was that you started
just interviewing him all right he
started asking him questions that had
nothing to do with total recall well
that was my pivot
yeah because we start off with total
recall which you know it's an amazing
movie we haven't touched upon yet i know
uh seth mentioned he's liked it online
so i think this is a great one to start
with and you know i had some fun facts
up my sleeves i did my research
and like you know 10 minutes into it i'm
like i'm talking about all these cool
facts from total recall
i need to stop talking and get our
guests talking
and so i guess there's some stuff to cut
nick
there is some stuff to cut yeah you got
my name
though i thought he was saying uh i
thought he had contributions to make i
didn't see it so much as you talking too
much and then uh it the when you did
start pivoting to ask actually asking
him filmmaking and industry questions it
felt like a very natural progression of
the moments you know it wasn't a bad
thing it was like i i definitely had a
nico we're talk we're supposed to be
talking about recall but also yeah what
do you say seth like what is your answer
i'm very curious
and the fact that i was thinking that in
the moment means that the audience is
not going to care about what we're
actually looking at looking at at the
moment it's like they want to know his
opinion yeah and it became the perfect
segue to this is the end which is a
movie that kind of encompasses
all the different aspects of production
for seth you know he was very involved
in a lot of different things that film
is everything from like here we had to
do photoreal monsters versus you know
deciding on practical effects of the
suit to
i'm writing jokes that have famous
people in them and we need to figure out
how to get them in the movie like
there's a whole slew of so many
interesting things that come up that you
have to problem solve so it was just
like such a good thing to jump into and
then once we hit that it was
we were off for the next
i wonder if he expected us to film for
three hours
i don't know
yeah we told him we told him that
christian okay well that's perfect good
yeah and we went in with the expectation
of getting two episodes out so you know
we shot two intros two outros stuff like
that and you know as a testament to just
how much of a professional seth is you
know he's done a lot of this sort of
thing before like nothing we did he
batted an eye out i was like this was
all par for the course for what he's so
used to
um yeah so i have one more question
before we move on to your tesla ren
um gosh okay
did he see my avatar
no yes but it wasn't operating
i commented i was like i don't know how
you didn't jump out of your skin when
you saw that he was like well i did
inside
i did inside
there you go jake there's the payoff for
the video right there that's coming out
this weekend
my uh my headphones have died
jordan
do you have airpods
what jake's referencing is
sneak peek for this sunday's video
still we built jake
a fully functioning autonomous avatar
for the studio i'm not going to go into
it further but that's all you need to do
is freaky it's pretty amazing every time
i walk into the studio now and it's
sitting there
i go i do a double take
this is one of those this is one of
those things you don't post on instagram
beforehand this is this is the one where
you leave it because it's so creepy
it's that's right it's too good but we
solved it we solved the problem we
solved it
i i somehow managed to not actually post
a video of the thing because i almost
did and i wanted to thank you and i i
kind of just forgot
to do it
just another sneak peek there's another
person involved with this
that basically had to dress up as you
and
and pretend to be you and when i saw
this person for the first time
i literally feel like i had a stroke
because my brain glitched out because i
look over and i saw you but it wasn't
you it was someone else's face and i
literally thought he was a real life
deep fake
like i literally thought a deep fake
just walked into the room because i was
playing smash bros i was just like huh
yeah i mean if you would have posted a
video of that it would have been some
really funny hype i wouldn't have been
yeah
but yeah i mean it's just uh i was just
like what what are you doing here
and yeah
it was great it was great that was all
that was all uh
really cool and that's i guess that
video is coming out this sunday coming
out sunday nick and i solved it it's
gonna be fun yeah it's yeah i think
that's gonna be a good video can i can
do a little segway for you to set up
this next segment of the podcast oh sure
okay
so
how's it getting ready for the seth
rogen
shoot which is a shoot that like i've
been prepping for for a couple days and
i'm i was decently nervous about
like
i embrace getting nervous because it
means that you're taking it seriously
and it heightens all your senses i agree
with that yeah yeah there's nothing
wrong with being nervous but ren had
something happen
that
shook
shook things up a little bit and i
remember you saying like we need to come
compartmentalize this because i can't i
can't focus on that right now
with seth rogen about to be coming in
and i need to do the vfx rs react
episode of a lifetime here so
wren what happened
so okay yeah okay so uh week and a half
ago or so or by the time you guys are
listening to this two weeks ago i got
into a car accident in my
beloved tesla model 3 that i've had for
three and a half years have almost 60
000 miles on it one of the first battle
threes it was in the first ten thousand
wow i had my reservation down for it
before the car was even announced
technically it was like the day of they
opened reservations that morning and i
went to a store and like put down my
deposit uh before i even knew what the
car was going to look like fortunately
it was awesome
i digress um yeah so i've had it for a
while it still took two years to finally
receive it but um
i got in a car accident i was on the
highway uh we were driving back from
oregon it was my wife and i jenna and
our two dogs and all of our luggage from
doing a week-long uh vacation and road
trip from la to oregon and back and we
are an hour away from la on our second
day of driving
and anyone who's ever driven on highways
can relate to this you know those
moments when you're going along and
traffic just slows down really quickly
and it's not like dangerously like quick
you're like oh okay okay and you're like
you're really pressing on the brakes and
it's it's a little herring it's a little
like nerve-wracking but it's not a big
deal
except for us
um we managed to stop uh in the car in
front of us there's enough room because
you know
i've been wearing it in the past and so
i'm always hyper like aware of the
amount of distance between myself and
cars in front and behind me and so
and jenna's the same way and so there's
a lot of room in front of us there's
also a lot of room behind us between us
and the car behind us
slowed down and that it came down to
just like a few feet on either side of
us but the pickup truck behind the car
behind us
wasn't able to stop in time for whatever
reason either he was tailgating too hard
tailgating is honestly i hate there are
a few things i hate more than tailgating
i mean there's a few things like that
irritate me more than uh just sloppy
drivers yeah you will kill somebody like
pay attention use your [ __ ] blinkers
yeah yeah exactly god damn it everybody
these are [ __ ] blinkers
really hard to use your blinker
yeah some people are psychos man yeah so
this guy i don't know for a fact if he
was on his phone or not but i'm like
you saw traffic slowing down you should
have been a like you could see it ahead
of you it wasn't like his the car in
front of him just slowed down really
quickly out of nowhere and he was like
oh gosh it's like
especially he was in a ford 250 super
cab i think it was a big truck with big
wheels and stuff like that he could
clearly see over every car in front of
us like literally looking down on us
probably on his phone yeah so i i i
deduced that he was probably on his
phone and simply didn't see the slow
down and so he hit the car which then
bumped into the back of my car and it
wasn't bad
we were within two feet of the car in
front of us and we didn't hit that car
so
we we didn't get hit that bad it was
just like kind of like you know
scrunched up next to us it broke the
bumper the bumper has to be replaced and
it crumpled up the the side panel a
little bit underneath the the charge
port and that was pretty much the extent
of the damage i've posted a picture of
this online you can clearly see it's not
that bad
so i've i then had to deal with you know
insurance claims uh getting a rental car
uh getting an estimate on the damage and
all that stuff and
you know i've been
i
i get a message
yesterday morning
technically i got i i'd gotten the
incident report
the day before and it was a breakdown of
the cost and it was going to cost thirty
thousand dollars to repair the car jesus
from a simple fender bender and i was
like
that's not valley
i i i mean okay i don't know the
reference um
i i i didn't i don't think i watched the
season with the tesla's in it um well he
can see a minor accident and it's going
to cost him 60 grand to fix it and then
he he gets all upset because
that's what it costs to fix it i mean
so that's pretty much exactly what
reality is when it comes to teslas
because i could not believe that it
would cost that much and it was around
like nine or ten thousand dollars in
parts and twenty thousand dollars in
labor
jeez and and when the the the estimate
had a breakdown was your like gold bar
holder like cracked or something like
that it might as well have been
can you only get it repaired
by a tesla certified mechanics you can
get it repaired elsewhere but it's not
wise and it's a lot harder to get the
parts um only tesla certified stations
can get like the oem parts that you'd
want to put back on your car anyway so i
was like and it had all of this stuff
in in small
small two words
total loss
oh my and i was like
but it was like right next to all these
terms that were defined like half of
this estimate was like literally
defining terminology and it was around
there and it said total loss and i was
like i think that was just i didn't
really internalize that that's what that
meant anyway the next morning i'm on my
way to work
uh to begin like trying to do all the
research for the seth rogen episode
because i've been really busy on this
other solar world video
uh i haven't really had time to like
research stuff so i was like okay
fortunately i've got hours ahead of me
no big deal
i get a call from jenna saying that the
tow yard had just called her sorry no
the auto body shop had called her saying
that geico is uh has deemed the car a
total loss and you have to come get the
car today
man
otherwise i'm going to start being
personally charged for all of the
storage fees
and they were steep
and i'm just i'm still i
in hindsight i realized i was going
through stages of grief and the first
one was i think denial and i just
couldn't believe it i was like there's
no way and i was starting to panic a
little bit and just like i was very
quickly becoming emotionally overwhelmed
and that's on top of just everything
else going on in my life and so i i i
called my cousin who was an insurance
adjuster and him and i both kind of
chatted a little bit about like what
this means then we together called the
actual guy who made the estimates and
this is like this went on for a freaking
hour and a half just kind of going into
the
the weeds of the details of why this was
deemed a total loss and so i understand
it now
so how how could a fender bender be a
total loss on this car so the first
thing we need to understand is that most
teslas are
or teslas are mostly made of aluminum
most of the body panels are aluminum
model 3s have more steel than the model
s and and whatnot but
it's very safe though right aluminum is
very strong well aluminum is very light
and it's almost as strong as steel so
it's it's a good substitute if if
lightweight is a priority which for
electric cars it is because a huge
amount of the weight of the car is
literally just the battery pack
and you know regular cars don't have to
deal with that so
a way they found to make the cars
lighter is to use more aluminum the
problem is that aluminum is incredibly
hard to work with it doesn't weld very
easily it doesn't uh
there's a bunch of problems with
aluminum and the way they designed their
cars
is in such a like we're gonna
we're gonna do one press
stamp of this thing and this is the
entire side panel of the car one quick
moving on uh you know teslas have some
of the most advanced
factory engineering of any car on the
market and
and so because of that if you
i i'm not really like
articulating myself very well but what
i'm trying to get at is
the side panel that got crumpled they
were going to need to replace but the
side panel goes all the way down and all
the way to the front of the car and wow
that is all the way the the aluminum is
mounted to the rest of the car it's
first riveted no first they glue it
and then they rivet it and then they
weld it
they have to have several uh layers of
protection for for the metal in case
like let's say the rivets start popping
uh the weld will hold it or if the glue
dries and the weld starts cracking the
rivets will hold it stuff like that and
they would have to cut into these panels
in such a way that will damage other
parts of the car
and so the estimate that i got the
reason why i couldn't understand it was
like what do you mean you have to
replace the roof what do you mean you
have to replace the a-pillars what do
you mean you have to replace the
flooring
none of that's damaged and they're like
we will have to break it in order to fix
what's broken
because the actual like if you're gonna
cut this stuff and weld it all the weld
sparks going up is gonna hit the the
the glass or just the heat of it will
cause things to expand and crack the
glass if they try to remove it the act
of removing the glass breaks the film
layer on top of the glass and so you
know
just due to liability concerns and
whatnot they're not legally allowed to
be like it's fine you know or like
so there's all these different steps
that they have to do that end up
creating bigger issues and so that
thirty thousand dollar estimate was also
just what they could see they don't know
what else once they actually start
removing stuff whatever else is going to
be there that is just going to make that
price go higher and
yeah and so like i i'm at a point now
where i at least understand why it was
deemed a total loss for what at first
appeared to be just a simple fender
bender and
yeah it's it's it's kind of devastating
i was really hoping to have this car for
10 years like this was like my long-term
car i was looking forward to yeah and so
and now i'm having to deal with what is
the current evaluation of this car the
value i should say uh on a current
market and all this stuff and it's a lot
less than what i originally paid for it
and
they're gonna say it's a lot so wren uh
in three years last time we had the
podcast you said the single best thing
anybody could do would be to
buy an electric car do you still yeah do
you still stand by those words i do so
the difference is that there's a
difference between an electric car and a
tesla
um tesla designs their cars in such a
way so that they're easy to produce
they're luxurious
and
they're incredibly safe incredibly
brittle
and they're actually the opposite of
brittle well
they're very squishy brittle in the
sense of rip repair reparations are
brittle
yeah and and it's like like uh the
bumper obviously broke is plastic you
can replace that and then there's this
impact
bar it's basically just a giant piece of
metal that's supposed to absorb some of
the impact that was going to have to be
replaced but there was a dent in the
actual body right underneath that so you
would have been fined if if the impact
had just gotten to the bar and not the
actual chassis of the car then
it was like had the car effectively been
half a foot to the left when it got hit
and it was only damaging just a little
bit of the body panel and like other
things weren't really hit it would have
been a completely different story in
fact at the the the auto body shop this
morning because i had to go get all my
stuff this morning
so that they can take it to the yard to
sell it at auction
i had to go get the rest of my stuff i
took a hubcap i took my my license plate
wait wait wait wait wait did you watch
it get sold at auction
no
that's like out of a movie
you got to do that you should have stood
there like in a black jacket and like a
black tie you know like it's a funeral
watching it tempted to like find out
more information about when it's going
to be sold at auction and then just
hype the hell out of it online be like
yo what up ah my trashed car is going on
auction here everyone show up i i don't
know why i'm being stuck it's like a
meme stock ryan go get it
i don't know i just i i'm very bummed
because
i would have loved to be able to like
harvest all the battery cells out of it
and stuff obviously they wouldn't want
me to do that in fact he straight up
said i couldn't when i asked um
uh wasn't it your car
well not once not if i want to have any
payout for it like break off the screen
and use it as a cool ipad
confused tesla's concept of ownership is
kind of
it yeah it's it's weird a little bit
another thing is that like
they they didn't initially uh value or
take into account the value of the
extended autopilot that i had and so
that you know i paid five thousand
dollars for that when i got the car or
that was rather a five thousand dollar
package which now doesn't exist
now you either get the stock car or you
pay like nine or ten grand for full
self-driving back when i got the car you
either had
literally nothing or the enhanced
autopilot which had a bunch of extra
features like summon you can control
your car with your phone navigate on
autopilot or
the third package which was the full
self-driving thing which i did not get
because it did not exist i do not
believe in in
buying a promise of something even
though that's literally exactly what i
did with the car
[Laughter]
that was the line i drew it was between
those two things i said i'll get your
car but you keep the autopilot all right
the full self-driving i got the entire
day don't come at me with that i don't
yeah so it's like you know and he didn't
so that that had dropped the value so
fortunately i was able to point that out
and he was able to include that which
increased the value a lot less than i
would have thought uh and but then i
also have all these free supercharger
miles
that you know from people using my
referral link all friends i don't think
anyone in the
fan
world or audience has uh really used
that for me i think one person did but
that's a thousand free supercharger
miles that you can quantify with value
like it costs this much so that's you
know a few hundred dollars worth of
stuff um
i had a bunch of that linked to my
account now i don't know for a fact if
that will transfer over to another car
if i was to get another tesla or if that
train if that's attached to the then so
whoever gets the car next will get that
if you're just to sell it
i don't know i was trying to like argue
that that was like quantifiable uh
value and the guy you know very quickly
shut me down with like no it's not uh
you know you can buy a car and get a
wrap put on it that doesn't you know if
if you
a dealership's not going to care it
doesn't inherently increase the value if
you put on fancy new reels or start
wheels that doesn't that cost five
thousand dollars that doesn't mean you
increase the value of the car by five
thousand dollars
in general that actually usually
specific buyers it actually usually
decreases the general market value for a
car the more you customize it oh really
yeah and now it does increase the value
to the right person
but
an insurance company is not that person
yeah so it's like one of those things i
was like okay fine yeah just having to
deal with all this and so now i'm in a
position of not even knowing if i can
afford another tesla
because i don't know how much money i'm
gonna get back because i'm still i'm
halfway through my loan you know and a
lot of i don't know what is called when
you when the interest is calculated for
the the term of the loan is calculated
upfront you're still paying a lot of the
principal or another person
there's a specific terminology for it i
can't remember but you end up it's
weighted so that you end up paying the
majority of the interest in the first
third or half
of the term of the loan yeah and then
most of the last half of the loan is
more about the principal so even though
i've had the car
even though i'm halfway through the loan
i'm less than halfway through it
monetarily if that makes sense but
halfway through the principle so i don't
exactly know where how much money i'm
going to get and whether or not that's
going to be able to completely pay off
the car
uh there are things in in uh to help
with that called gap coverage but that's
on the finance side of things
um yeah
yeah and it's just a lot that you have
to consider that you don't really think
about when you buy a car and so let's
say i do get a bunch of
enough money that i could put money down
on another tesla if i decide to do that
another thing i have to take into
account is sales tax for a car like that
you're looking at four to five thousand
dollars at least just in sales tax that
you have to pay up front you can't put
that on the loan
and
it's that's easy to forget
so got an ft sale coming up in two days
i mean
maybe you'll be thinking about this next
time you buy a car
i mean and
yeah
anything in my life once it's happened i
consider
sorry this is just i i'm sorry that this
happened it sucks
but it's also great
and it i'm just
it's
i don't exactly understand what the
learning experience is here
the fact that i got screwed over because
you don't want to understand what the
learning experience is here
let me rephrase i don't understand what
you think the learning experience is
here the learning experience in my
opinion is that you were a very vocal
and avid early adopter of this
technology and now you're suffering some
of the consequences because the market
for the technology has not caught up to
the people who have early adopted it and
it maybe it will and it probably will
eventually and things are moving in that
way but you took a bet early by being an
early adopter and sometimes that's what
happens sometimes you pay for it and so
that's the learning experience i think
that's a slightly unfair perspective if
i was to do this over again i wouldn't
change it i would definitely 100 percent
unequivocally do it again well then you
haven't learned anything from the
experience
i don't think the lesson you see here is
one worth learning i think
i
the i i'm still a hundred percent
believer in electric cars in general i'm
still not saying a believer in a tesla
as the best car yeah but what the thing
is is that you're taking what could be a
financial loss on this
when next time there's new financial
realities that you will probably
consider
and the idea of i'm going to
just grab this
without even having seen the car
maybe that'll be
maybe that maybe you'll think twice
about that
i mean part of me saying that was also
pointing out how ignorant it was to do
that uh well yeah no i and i get that
well the situation see what you're
saying the situation will be this would
also be the same with any car like one
insurance is pretty apt to total cars
they are yeah um they often write off
cars as total losses
and you're gonna be in the same
financial situation regardless of
whether or not it's a tesla if the car
is written now if you're in the same
exact boat of like
you lose money and if it's not your
fault you're gonna lose money and yeah
that's kind of life taking the crap five
years ago i i had that vw uh
uh gli it was like a jetta type deal i
was really happy with it and i got rear
ended again and that car was deemed a
total loss because of the framework
damage
and i was like year into owning that car
and i ended up kind of getting screwed
in exactly what i just described uh
it was fine i didn't lose money on i
didn't owe any money i should say but it
was like
i got screwed
that's the moral of that story is like
you know that's what happens when you
get in car accidents i guess the concern
it brings to me though about tesla's if
there were was a lesson is like are they
as repairable or you know and it seems
like the answer is no i already see
that's the thing i already
thought i understood that teslas were
hard to work on they already i already
knew about their reputation for like oh
it's going to cost a lot of money to
repair
i just didn't connect that with the idea
that
well first off that it could happen to
me it can
no you never think about how things
could happen to you you know
it can happen but then
this is why i'm bringing it up because
like that's
that's that's part of the
process that no and everybody goes
through yes and i'm saying i have now
learned that and it's not changing how
i'm going to act
in terms of my perception of a tesla
it's that's why i had really good
coverage on the car first off and
that coverage is helping me through this
so it's
yeah you know
i mean it's definitely like
anytime somebody's jumping into a
vehicle that's a high-end vehicle
i mean it's the same thing it's like
same thing as buying a house honestly
it's like it's not just the cost of the
car that you have to consider when you
do that and there's also the the what is
you know it's like what if you do get an
accident how do you handle that how do
you handle sales taxes you mentioned
rent how do you handle insurance i got a
speeding ticket uh oh spring my first
speeding ticket in like a decade oh no
uh my insurance went up a thousand
dollars a month
a year
a year well actually might be it might
be happening
these are the things though like these
types of life experiences that you only
learn because it happens to you or it
happens to somebody that you know
they should really go they should really
teach scenarios like this in high school
they do when the bully takes your lunch
no i mean like you should have gotten
such a nice lunch
you teach like
teaching a course called like practical
economics right and it's about buying a
car it's about buying a house it's about
doing your taxes
and you actually agree actually like
give people your grade
isn't based on how well you learn the
concepts it's based on how much money
you're left with at the end of the
course
and you have a fake amount of money that
you have to start with and you have to
make purchasing decisions along the way
and then you have like a value based on
like how much money you started with
versus the value of your assets at the
end
and that's an act that's what your grade
is based on that'd be great i think
that's a really interesting idea and i
would love to see
that sort of concept applied more often
in schools that would be great
because going into the real world i had
no idea how to do taxes it's not one of
those things where it's like wait
everybody does this
they didn't teach me anything everyone's
getting screwed how many people are
getting screwed
everybody
don't worry dude so we can go and you
know bring freedom to the east
yeah i mean whether or not you're
getting screwed just the realization
that like
just this is a process
whether or not it's it's just when
everybody gets screwed you know what i
would argue that there's some taxes that
are justified and in fact if the
government is holding taxes that are
justified nico
not most of them
and and to be clear i i i understand i
was also kind of getting defensive there
jake like
i'm not happy about this situation if
this is still incredibly fresh it's
barely been 24 hours since i've started
down the steps of grief here that i
outlined earlier um
and and so yeah i'm not exactly stable
around any of this so i thought you were
kind of attacking me for something that
i thought was unfair but at the same
time i'm still also kind of sticking
with my
what i said it's like
yeah there are definitely some things to
learn here but it's
and it is going to affect my perception
of the the sort of pros and cons of
buying another tesla but at the same
time
i need another vehicle
and i cannot foresee how it can be any
other vehicles
i mean that being said i i have like
what two or three weeks left on my
rental and then i'm out so i'm like can
you use your own reference code
oh there you go
there you go if not can you use mine
please
you just got divs you just got dibs um i
so i mean the problem is that like if i
was to buy a tesla right now
i have two options i can buy it used or
brand new and if i buy it used the
entire marketplace is
high right now expensive used cars are
everywhere or rather let me that was a
weird way of phrasing it um
just the market itself the valuation of
used cars is way up in general and so 12
basically over the last six months
oh my god wow and so yeah and so i'm
like i can either do that or i can buy a
brand new car and go through the same
loan process and extend it out into the
future again
um but even if i was to choose that
route
i i would have to wait at least three
months to receive the car
like
i mean potentially longer who knows what
it is because it kind of changes this is
your chance to build the one wheel car
think about it
this is
this is finally your chance
so what you do is you get a chassis
right and you take the wheels from four
one wheels and you get like axises and
like a motor in the center and you link
them all together with a drivetrain and
you're in like a seat in the middle
you already did that did he really
made a yeah out of one wheel motors and
tires you did yeah okay god dang it
chance that's okay he
had a lot of help there goes our
show
but yeah it was like this little like
go-kart thingy which is like a roll bar
and that was basically it but it was a
bunch of one wheels with the motors
um it was for some show i never got to
see it i looked it up i couldn't
literally couldn't watch it was a tv
show that didn't have any sort of
internet streaming outlet
um
anyway
i what i think i'll probably end up
doing in the short term here is actually
buying a different car just buy the
cheapest used car i possibly can
therefore having the highest resale
value it could
like you did with the leaf yeah like
kind of what i did with the nissan leaf
because i only had that nissan leaf for
like six months before i got the tesla
and i was able to sell it for almost the
same amount of money i bought it for so
i ended up basically just having a free
car for six months does jenna have a car
she does have a car yeah you ever think
about just maybe getting like a really
nice e-bike until you get around to the
second tesla well i was wait sorry real
quick we haven't asked this question
just putting out there are you going to
get a tesla for your second car i i'm i
mean
he just said he can't live without it
it's it's it's
if you're a betting man yeah i would bet
on that
but i i haven't decided you know i've
barely even had a chance to
think about any of this because i found
out the car was totaled and had to be
like okay that sucks there's a lot going
through my head right now that i
literally can't think about because in
an hour seth rogen's going to be here
and i have to turn it on so i can be on
camera and then that was the entire rest
of the day and by the end of shooting i
had one of the worst headaches i had
ever had really and pretty much just
went straight home and just like did
nothing and then woke up this morning
and had to go
uh
pick a pocket the corpse
i dilute the
squat hit x and got my license plate
uh
do one last selfie with it and then
leave it and come in and then you know
hit the ground running on the solar
world video which
we now have a final timeline
by the way of everything that i i wrote
we've shot nice uh we have a full
timeline
this video is 23 minutes long that's
awesome
it's about three times longer than an
average video of these that i make and
so
it is
i'm now like okay well at least it now
makes sense why it's been taking me so
long just to write it
and film it
there's just a lot you make a full
television episode
yeah and so just right off the bat it's
already like one of the most ambitious
things i've ever done and that's before
taking into account any sort of visual
effects of which i've been trying really
hard to
keep realistic and and tone down so
there's a lot of to make up for that
anytime i'm on camera we have more
dynamic shots that matt and i had
planned so that there's at least
something interesting visually happening
at all times
instead of just me talking to a tripod
that's really smart there are some
there's a lot of that in this video but
there's also a lot more just generally
interesting visuals and uh overall
it's gonna get paired down it's probably
gonna be a lot less than 23 minutes you
just make an episode of television real
quick
yeah no big deal
but i mean yeah so i'm that's like been
my 100 of my focus like i worked all
weekend on this thing just trying to get
it to a point so that i can hand it off
because i knew i wasn't going to be able
to spend that much time on it this week
between all the filming we're filming
two react episodes got this podcast
today we've got research for these react
episodes we're doing a crew uh uh render
challenge on friday it's like oh wait we
are oh hell yeah
surprise
it's been on the calendar so i'm not
surprised what's the rendering challenge
gonna be again we're going to find out
yeah we'll talk about it later yeah but
yeah so i guess what i'm saying is that
like this is valuable time i can't just
let be wasted so i had to get the video
to a point that i could kind of step
away from it and without losing time so
i've just been a hundred percent all in
on this while also just dealing with
this car stuff i have an idea i've just
been overwhelmed i also have a headache
right now this headache hasn't really
gone away in the last 24 hours i've been
taking ibuprofen i've been drinking a
lot of water it's still here this is a
spa day buddy yeah you need a massage
wren i had a massage last wednesday we
could go today oh well i went to massage
it was incredible oh that's the other
thing i started physical therapy so
every every other morning i've been
getting up earlier to go literally do
exercises and stretches with my shoulder
and that's also causing pain
well
if you want to hear some funny karma i i
pulled my shoulder
so bad
a night ago yes the day before yesterday
the morning before this morning
it is still so bad and i think it's
because of all the making fun of you i
did when you broke your
[Laughter]
collarbone it's like uh it's better it's
just a drag tonight jake because uh
yeah
off the road
dude i know i know that's yeah exactly
yeah
i thought you were setting up an
elaborate way to make fun of me no i was
like oh you didn't actually you did
plenty of that yeah i already did enough
of that today but no seriously it's it's
been rough man i gotta i gotta get some
i've been trying to stretch it but it's
like there's only so much i can do
yeah
and you know it's funny i didn't realize
this but my uh whatever this neck muscle
is here the trapezius the trapezoid
the whatever this muscle is here
has gotten buff
over the last few months
it's more like like triangle uh
tumor it's triangle tumor
and it's because of the compensation
i've not been able to raise my arm and
so i've been doing a lot more shrugging
and i hadn't realized i remember when i
was like oh yeah it's fine i'm able to
reach out now but i was like literally
leaning out like this just to raise my
arm yeah and
it's in this video this solar video like
there's literally a moment where i reach
down i pick up a rock and then i squeeze
it and i squeeze a bunch of oil out of
it and it falls to the ground um but
when i lift it i do one of those like
[Laughter]
one of these things i'm like oh it was
wrong i'm fine
and i'm just like looking at the footage
and i'm like why do i look so weird and
i didn't understand it until i started
doing physical therapy and she was
describing how my muscles all like tight
knotted up my bicep has actually like
receded a little bit it's shorter so
that's the whole thing that we're
working on and
yeah physical therapy has actually been
great i've been enjoying it you're
suffering from a short bicep
well yeah so it was like it was that
context when i finally saw that shot
again i was like oh that's what i'm
doing i'm literally seeing what she was
describing all the shrugging and that's
cool
physical therapy man maybe i should give
it a shot for a little bit my shoulders
are a little screwed up too oh yeah look
into it stay like scott atkins says stay
balanced
yep that's true
i should probably stretch instead of
physical therapy just do any exercise
that's a good one i mean actually yeah
exercise in general is great i just
realized this morning i can finally play
beat saver again oh yeah i hadn't even
considered it until like literally this
morning i guess they released a new
skrillex map pack oh really and i'm like
okay that sounds pretty cool for beat
saber that's gonna be great but too bad
i can't play wait a minute
and then i literally just like
i was in in bed reading a tweet about it
and i i was just like
yeah
we're back let's go
you know they got a 66v66 mode going on
pop one right now
oh my god i should play some pop one too
tonight you guys want to go play pop one
after two i honestly would be down i
think it's dude
dude i am we're gonna play some pop one
it's gonna be great let's sit down
screen capture real quick uh here hold
on wait wait hold your arms out like
this
yeah like straight okay turn uh
actually just do it with your right hand
straight up yeah there you go dude trust
them
that's perfect okay what i'm capturing
right now turn it a little bit more
towards niko
it's like your arm is on the side where
the participants are but then it's
sticking out in the mainframe
it's super weird i'll share it i'll
we'll put it on here for a second okay
yeah because i have no idea what you're
talking about
cutting the screen cap sorry for audio
only i just had to do that
[Laughter]
um yeah
but anyway i guess what i'm saying is
that
you know
shitty stuff sometimes happens
it is what it is there's no value and
dwelling on things that happen to you
and
it's the only thing that actually
matters is what you do about it
and so i had one of the best days of
work ever yesterday sitting on a couch
with you and seth rogen that was
incredible and and you and basically the
whole seth rogen crew is in this room
right now like christian
um
like that was that was like an actual
honor and it is objectively cool
it also just happened to be on the same
day that i was borderline having a
nervous breakdown
yep
and and so it's like i guess yeah
i'm keeping my head up i'm moving
forward it doesn't
there's yeah i i acknowledge that
there's no use in being angry about it
there's no use in like
getting upset that this happened
it happened it is what it is i'm moving
on i'm going to make wiser decisions in
the future i'm going to have more
considerations thanks to these
experiences and who knows maybe this was
for the best maybe my next car is going
to be even better maybe i'll be like in
hindsight like well that was actually a
pretty good thing this ended up working
out better than i expected it will be
made so who knows i know that new leaf
dude is really dope
the model wise ain't bad either i know i
and that see that's the thing i don't
know if i'd get a model 3 or a model y
well there you go yeah
i can't afford either
yeah gap insurance all right we did a
really solid job compartmentalizing that
and yeah you're glad you were able to do
that so that that way you're able to
enjoy the day with seth rogen
and it's like if people are end up
watching that episode and are like oh
wow and he was struggling with all that
behind the scenes it's like yeah i was
but in the moment that none of that was
on my mind i was there i was having a
good time that was real yeah so
yeah money comes and goes and material
items do too but experiences stay with
you forever yeah because you know
i hear it all the time especially
because i posted about it everyone's
like well at least you're okay and it's
like yes you're right but also
but yes
everyone and everything that actually
matters is fine so ultimately
no worries
dang what a podcast that's a great yeah
you have that little uh
finger
yeah here i'll play a little sentimental
yeah i thought you were on your phone
when i watched like the chill podcast oh
my god nick's just chilling i thought
the same thing
it's just like he's using a 1990s
smartphone
the big ones but he's got like the
screen
ren
you'll get a new car one day
i might buy a prius
really
if i could find one super cheap
hey if anyone out there
lives within a couple hundred miles of
la and you want to get rid of your prius
super cheap let me know
super cheap
we need a corridor we're talking about
pawn shop prices yeah like
hey jake i i got a task for us this
could be a crew cuts video
riding the jingle for the crew or the
quarter cast yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
see you're making that same mistake
again
yeah syncopation yeah don't you think of
patients when you have two different
rhythms playing on top of each other
damn it he's right yeah this takes us
back full circle to the freaking opening
of this this podcast are you ready
three three two
one